I heard and I want you to clarify I  heard rumors that originally at the end  of the credits of wakanda forever you  were going to have a a final credit  scene was that ever the case no actually  uh uh and I've heard those rumors too no  you know I think the subject matter of  the film was such that it it didn't feel  appropriate to have than like a stinger  you know what I mean much like uh end  game felt like an emotional experience  that you also didn't need like a Stinger  at the end of this this felt like we we  just wanted to tell the story as as as  it was conceived without uh without an  added added bonus so unfortunately there  isn't an end credits